okay hello hi okay so I'm Muslim and I
would like to understand like what is
going on here sure I'm a Christian and
by reading the Quran I've seen some
things that would disqualify Allah from
being God God being all powerful all
knowing stuff like that right so there
okay so you're the unguided I am the
guided actually okay continue yes so I
believe that the ones who think that
Allah is God are the unguided ones I'm
on the straight path okay so for example
we you and I would agree that God by
definition is all powerful right most
definitely all right good so my question
to you is this if Allah wanted to could
he have a son no so he's not all
powerful he is but that's not in his
attributes to do something like that
right it's not in his attributes to be
able to have a son if he wanted to so
therefore he's not all powerful he's
well he's not a creation right son
biological that's limited to like like
this species this creation God is Not
Like Us he's not your your brain is
limited and it cannot even fathom that
there is this being that's not like a
son father biological thing like that so
that does not apply to him I see so do
you know that you just went against what
your Quran says the I nothing I said
went against my Holy Quran yeah your
Quran says that if Allah wanted to he
could have a son he would just take one
from one of his Creations so what's your
issue well you just contradicted the
Quran how did I contradict the Quran you
said that Allah couldn't have a son if
he wanted to when the Quran says he
could because you would try to use it
and twist it so I'm not gonna fall for
that I think that you fell for your own
s you're the Quran as the truth if you
are accept then you accept it in its
entirety okay don't try to twist certain
things right right all right so and this
and honestly this is a simple topic and
father I agree that's a simple what what
is something that you have that's deeper
I think that this is I think that
Simplicity is always effective you know
not all of us can go super deep I'm a
very simple man myself I'm not the
smartest Bunch so the simple the simple
arguments and the simple Concepts to me
resonate and usually resonates with the
viewers so
I would say this so then can I Reas you
the question now that we know what the
Quran says could Allah have a son if he
wanted to no like he like I I know what
you mean and like I know that you're
saying like it's in the Quran but like I
don't like I don't want to say like such
a thing right okay I don't want to like
affirm like such a thing but it's but
you would be okay to affirm that because
Allah affirms it himself in the Quran so
you're not you wouldn't yeah so take
yeah so take the quran's word for it
whatever the Quran says I agree with it
so do you believe that Allah if he
wanted to could have a son like in the
sense as like like birth one yeah he's
not like us like he's not like his
creation but he says that he could do it
if he wanted to so do you believe him in
the sense as in like he's unlimited
andow and can do anything like anything
you can imagine anything you can imagine
okay all right good so it looks like
we're on the same page that if Allah
wanted to because he's all powerful and
could do anything you can imagine he
could have a son if he wanted to correct
he can do anything he wants like
anything you can so because I want to
hear you say it so he could if he wanted
to have a son correct I just like say
like personification and like biologic
like I don't want to do that so like
whatever you're saying like we can put a
check no cuz I you cuz you're a Muslim I
I don't want us to check something that
you're not comfortable with saying if
you're not comfortable with affirming
what Allah said about himself just say
that no I am but I don't want to use
like these words like he like he like
but he uses these words see I'm not
giving you something he didn't say
himself he uses these words okay I guess
yeah sure good so Allah can have a son
he has the same attributes that we do he
could have a son if if he wanted to yes
oo that's tough now let me ask you this
okay if he wanted to have a son could he
do it by himself or would he need a wife
see this is such a weird thing to like
get into like I don't even want to
imagine such you wanted deep you you
wanted to get deep though didn't you but
not like this is simple that's what I'm
saying like the overall what you're
covering like can God like give like you
know have a wife and like give birth and
stuff like that like that's not that
that's not something that he does or he
needs to do because he's self-sufficient
I agree it's not something that he does
nor does he need to do it which isn't my
my question my question is could he if
he wanted to could he have a son like
okay we already said that he could if he
wanted to but would he need a wife to
have the son or could he have a son by
himself I mean of course he if he says
be like it would be he doesn't need he's
self-sufficient he can do whatever he
wants exactly so if he needed if if he
couldn't do that by himself then that
would like that would show that he's not
all powerful right right right and
therefore it wouldn't be God cuz God is
all powerful sure okay okay so you and I
agree that Allah is not all powerful
because he also says this in chapter 6
verse 101 of the Quran he says how can
Allah have a son when he doesn't have a
wife so according to this verse in order
for Allah to have a son he would need a
wife he couldn't do it by himself okay
so pull up the verses side by side okay
is there a way for you to do that yes
let me um let me get this for you let me
go ahead and kind of minimize my YouTube
stream a bit all right okay so chapter 6
verse 101 I'mma pull that up and I'mma
show it on the screen for you so you can
see it and then we'll look at the other
verse also that says he could if he
wanted to take a son he could have taken
it from any of his creation all right so
that's 611 all right uh oo and actually
I'm having a brain fart guys what's that
verse where it says if he wanted to he
could take a son from his creation
what's that verse guys text it to me if
you oh don't text it to me because I'm
not going to get anything guys what's
that verse I'm having a brain fart we
were just using it too by the way
where's 100 when you need them someone
else said that they forgot help me 30 30
which one is it is it 394 or 349 I'm
getting all tipotype answers you guys s
394 all all right 394 so let's let's
pull that up too let's pull up that
Quran 39 verse4 yes here it is all right
so let's go ahead and pull this tab out
let's put this up here let's pull this
tab out like this okay all right all
right there we go all right so going to
open my screen for you okay so this is
the one who that says that he could have
a son if he wanted to okay so this
chapter 39:4 are you with me sister yes
all right so it says had Allah willed to
take a son he could have chosen whom he
pleased Out Of Those whom he created but
glory be to him he is Allah the one
they're irresistible so if he wanted to
take a son he could have if he wanted to
could have chosen any thing from any of
his creation to have a son he could have
done it but here over here this verse
says that he would need a wife to do it
he is the originator chapter 6 ver 101
he is the originator of the heavens and
the Earth how can he have children when
he has no wife he created all things and
he is the allower of everything there
you go there's your answer what do you
mean it says he has no wife like he's
asking you right yeah he's saying say he
like how can he do this if he has no
wife exactly he's asking you then he's
telling you because he is the creator of
all things well know her well no it's
it's it's denying that he has a son and
it's saying how can have a son how can
he have children when he has no wife
okay so he created all things and he is
the know all knower of everything it's
rejecting this idea that Allah has a
partner and has any children it's
rejecting it saying that he would need
he he would need a wife to have a son so
because he doesn't have a wife he
doesn't have children and just
everything is just his creation not his
children you get what I'm saying no
because I'm telling you that it answers
it right there so it's asking you right
like how can he have children when he
has no wife right like how can he have
no children when he has no wife yes so
he's answering it by saying he is the
creator of all things no it's not
answering the question it's it's telling
you that he's just the creator of all
things the problem is that Allah cannot
have a son without a wife and he is just
the creator of all things you are just
his creation you're not his sons or his
daughters not right so you're just his
cre you're just his creation that's it
so it's yes amongst other things well
well no well I mean so you can be all
these other things let's give you that
except for his children you get it God
is not limited this verse says he is no
but how when he's saying literally he
ends it right like it's a poem okay that
like that's how you read the entire
Quran actually it's just a poem so he's
ending it with like the glory it's not
ending it with like I'm I'm limited like
I would not be able to like I'm so weak
like I would not be able to have a son
if I didn't have a wife duh like I need
my creation we're like the last of these
like beings that we know of I don't I
don't get the conclusion there it's
literally rejecting this idea that Allah
has any children and one of the
objection is cuz he doesn't have a wife
you're just his creation he can't have
children if he doesn't have a wife first
of all God is not like that to have like
a spouse and things like that like we
don't like associate that with him he
did remember we just saw it he just yeah
so he's like trying to he's like trying
to tell you basically like he's trying
to fix your idea of what you think God
is like your idea of God is so like it's
illogical for you to think what you
think about Jesus being God so he's
trying to fix your logic with this verse
it has nothing to do with Christians
it's not addressing Christians it's
addressing the polytheist okay
okay well you so it's addressing the
polytheus but I would I would agree with
you that this would apply to this would
apply to an objection to Christianity
when I mean kind of but not really
because Allah Allah is seems to think
that people believe that he has children
by sexual intercourse that that's the
only way to have kids which is not the
Christian belief so he doesn't even know
what we believe he gets our belief wrong
when he addresses it let me ask you this
did Mary have a like Mary had a son
right was she married when she had a son
no no she wasn't right she was she was
she was she didn't have intercourse in
order to have Jesus she was a virgin
right yet she was able to have a son
without a consort without a husband of
course how was that how was that able to
be done because if God says be then it
will be so how was it then that Mary was
able to have a son without a husband but
Allah can't have a son without a wife
all can do anything except have a son
without a wife no he tells you in that
verse that he like he can do anything he
created all things okay so are they his
children no we don't think that he has
like he doesn't H do things that humans
do like have kids and have wives and
that's not what he does right so he
can't have he existed long before the
idea of humans like long long before
like we existed there so many things
before us he's not like to come in like
the Flesh of a human for us like that's
not going to happen Okay we're not like
that I mean like we are so important in
a in a sense but like you really think
like I don't know like it's not we're
not like like we need God but God like
doesn't need us let me uh let me let me
certain things like that like make your
like you know be crucified and stuff
like that
well let me let me change directions a
bit for with you why why do you believe
that Islam is the truth for you
specifically well like if you were to
give me the best reason why Islam is the
truth why what what is it because I I
believe in goodness so I I like see what
promotes goodness okay so like I'm a
female right so like it's important for
me that like men don't sexualize me or
objectify me so like Islam it's so like
I'm so protected right like I'm I'm
covered and I don't have to conform to
society and get certain things done to
my body that I'm never going to be happy
with because nobody's gonna see it got
gotta my Mak hold
on just wait for the sister to come back
make sure you guys are liking this uh
this live make sure you guys are liking
especially if you're liking this
conversation and if you like where this
is about to go hit that like button if
you guys if you guys where this is about
to go it's that time okay not not you're
like lowkey kind of freaking me out but
okay whatever don't don't be scared hold
on let me I don't know what okay what
did I get myself into
lowy yeah go ahead okay so but I'm yeah
okay but do you do you understand what
I'm trying to say like for like a
religion that's promoting goodness right
like to me that's good so these like
Muslim countries right like where
there's mostly covered women like this
is good like this okay like this path is
like good and then like the Christian
countries there's like so much like
promiscuities just rampant like like
anybody like that I uh like you know
meet eventually or whatever like right
it's so so rampant so yeah like I would
want to deter from and that's just one
example okay well let's go with that I
like I like your answer actually that
you you lean towards Islam and you
believe it's true because it promotes
goodness and you see the fruition of its
goodness a matter of fact like I think
that the religion right that you like
right when you're assessing right when
you're follow so let me address this
okay let me address this okay because I
I I I like what you said however so if a
religion is not professing goodness
right then it would show that it is
actually not from God because God is
good he would not pro promote evil or
wrongdoing would you agree but goodness
on like what scale on the scale that you
just said like for example the
protection of women the the non
objectifying women right um seeing you
know let's just talk about human women
as a yeah when I'm not yeah so if I
think like really quickly some top
things like that's going to be like my
top five okay yeah start uh with that
yeah yeah okay yeah we we'll stick with
that allow uh like uh rules and stuff to
take uh form but let wait
let's stick with that let's stick with
this good let's stick with this so the
treatment of the goodness and treatment
of women
morality is a thing that you are like
that's number one for you that's how you
see that Islam is the truth got you do
you have a Quran on you by the way if
not I could just show it on the screen
it sounds like you got also got your
kids with you so I I could do the work
for you and just put on the screen okay
sure okay so I'm going to pull up
chapter 4 and I'm going to pull up verse
34 okay all right CH
4:34 cool okay here it is me just go
ahead actually kind of starts off like
it's pretty good we'll see you see it
you see the screen I'm about to read it
okay go ahead okay so it says men are
the managers of the Affairs of women for
that God has Preferred in Bounty one of
them over the other and for that they
have expended of their property
righteous women are therefore obedient
guard guarding the secret of God's
guarding and those you may those you
fear may be rebellious So it's talking
about how to treat your wives right
those who you fear may be rebellious
admonish them banish them to their
couches and beat them if they then obey
you look not for any way against them
God is all high all great do you think
that this is good to teach that not if
not even if you did anything wrong but
if you fear she may do something wrong
you can beat your wife man could beat
their wife so let's break this down
because you're not even the word
property it's that's women so like where
is like what are you using first of all
this is the Quran this chapter 4:34 I
know but property like all of my Quran
say women no uh what are you talking
about first of all like you're like
making like no and that's not the only
word there's so many words words in this
that's like it's this word right here
this word is property look but it's the
most negative word that you can think of
it's I hear you let's let's go to the
Arabic it breaks down the Arabic so
let's look at it word for word let's go
to that word property let's see what it
was okay so your women because mow Allah
some of them over others and because
they spend from okay the word is wealth
let me read it let me read mine okay
mine is not like nasty like yours what
do you mean word is wealth or property
in the Arabic okay it's not women
everybody agree okay that the way that
yours is phrasing it like there's
something wrong really something wrong
with the Quran husbands yeah husbands
are the protectors and maintainers of
their wives because Allah has given the
one more strength than the other right
like men are stronger than women yeah
and because they support them from their
means so provide for them yeah so the
means wait wait so the means are their
property right and their expenses their
wealth they spend of their wealth or
their property on the women like they
take care of them right well yeah like
whatever I guess yeah so it it wasn't
necessarily so I think you misunderstood
my like what I had on the screen is it
wasn't saying that the women are
property it was saying that they spend
their property on there were some other
like okay I I guess I just wanted to
read it from mine because I just sure go
ahead sorry like yeah so from their
means therefore the right righteous
women are devoutly obedient and guard in
the husband's absence what Allah would
have them guard as to those women on
Whose part yeay fear disloyalty and Ill
conduct admonish them first refuse to
share their beds spank them but if they
return to obedience okay seek not
against them means for Allah is most
high and great so this is referring to
the women like the women on o so it's
just say women like slap them straight a
little bit butal like literally so you
think that it's okay for a husband to
slap his wife it's not referring to
husband and wife he's it is this is
literally talking about husband and wife
literally it says men are if the wife
yeah okay what if if she's married or if
she's not married right like if she just
Strays and she's getting on o or
whatever like he needs to like slap her
silly so it's it's okay for a man to hit
a woman you think that's good but not
like abuse not don't don't abuse her
like you again I'll ask you again is it
okay is it good for a man to beat his
wife in in the sense of like girl what
are you doing you're like somebody she's
paused so she probably got a call or
something are you back oh did I leave
you yeah it was something happened I
don't know what happened oh um it
literally says spank so it's telling you
like the it says beat them actually it
says the word is Strike them not spank
but it's okay go that's why I didn't
like your definition you're it seems
like it's using like the worst word no
that's that's the word in Arabic the
word in Arabic duraba means to stri stke
them look yeah there's many but in this
context right like thist we're talking
about women's rights right like this is
a feminine like we're appealing to like
women yeah so do you think that it's
good do you think that it's good for
women's rights that men are able to hit
them this is telling me like if I like
did something bizarre right no it
doesn't it says if you fear that she may
be rebellious so you don't even have to
do something if they fear that you might
do something or might be disobedient
they can strike you just to let you know
when you pause I can't hear you so okay
sorry I didn't the pop up okay no it's
not what are you talking about fear the
men is not fearing yes it look it says
and you can even read it in your own
translation as well right before it
talks about admonishing them it says if
you fear look and those you fear may be
rebellious so so you you think that they
might be rebellious not not that that
you actually wasn't rebellious yes okay
keep okay keep going right admonish them
banish them to their couches right so
don't sleep with them what does admonish
them mean like correct them telling you
yeah like verbally telling you okay and
then so if they don't listen then they
don't no it doesn't say if they don't
listen these are all things that you do
it's not no no no no no no no no no no
it's like a why why would you just no
you have to like if she's going to
engage in something that's wrong right
like you're not going to just spank her
you're going to tell her first it
doesn't say that she's engaging in
anything wrong it says look admonish
admonish them first it doesn't say first
that's not in the Arabic okay admonish
them first and then why do you keep
doing that it doesn't say first in the
Arabic it's not telling you to why one
is greater than the other right so first
you're talking to her right Habibi
whatever then next you're gonna not if
she doesn't listen now you're not going
to sleep with your wife you're it's like
telling you like okay refrain from like
the intercourse with her she's done a
year and then do what and and then you
have to lightly it doesn't say lightly
it doesn't say lightly don't do that
yours that's what I'm saying yours says
yours is taking the like it's the same
meaning but your words are like the most
like like it's what the Quran says it's
what the Quran says it's not mine it's
like no you're reading it like uh that's
what I'm saying like maybe go find
another go find another Quran go go find
one more no seriously you're like you're
not reading you're right you're right
you right you know what this Quran this
quran's corrupted let me let me choose
another one let me choose another one
that's what I'm saying like don't use
words like that okay that's why I said
it's the same meaning but you're using
the most negative synonyms what do you
mean negative synonyms that's what it
says so even even the word property is
so negative that I immediately was like
I could and even before another one says
Scourge them o that's tough Scourge them
do you know what to Scourge means like
that means you beat the mess out of
something it has you beat it up that's
what that's what this I got I got a
different you ask me to get a different
one I got a different one well another
one let's get a different one that one's
corrupted too what you Al say all right
this one says beat them but in
parentheses which is not in the actual
text the commentator adds lightly this
is not in the Quran
they add this this is what it says yes
because this is yes yes yes it's
clarification for you people who speak
Arabic they understand okay this is
clarification for you to help you all
right so I got you I got you I don't
want to use the ones that are trying to
help me I want to stick to this one that
makes it look like you do I used I went
I used three of them you said the first
one was was corrupted you didn't like
the second one that said to Scourge you
and so this one says beat them it's okay
it's okay so look this is my question
all right you see like do you think it's
okay to give a permission for a man to
beat his wife even lightly you think
that that's okay for women's rights so
the word beat and lightly like I don't
think they go in the same sentence
together because you say beat before you
even say lightly I've already had a
vision of like what good I'm glad okay
so I don't say you can't say like be
lightly well that's thank you so it's
not say so that's what hold on you you
keep pausing sister when you when you
pause when you like when you leave the
app yeah when whenever you leave the app
it's going to pause you and I can't I'm
not leaving the app it's uh my
connection sorry oh okay okay so look
this is my question this is It's a
simple question for you and I is it ever
okay for a man to beat his wife no and
no man in Islam should beat his wife and
we don't promote that well the Quran
does no no no no first of all okay I
can't I got to go oh my God okay if if
you need to go it's okay like follow me
we can continue this next time no I just
want to explain it really quickly I
don't want to end on that that's so bad
so don't exaggerate it okay don't
exaggerate right like I am not
exaggerating just we just read I know I
know but Islam is very firm so he's like
Allah is I see yeah no he's like tell
like he's describing like fir you know
like he's describing like what you
should do in a situation like this she's
like o right you go and you talk to her
say huh what is O are you saying only
fans
yeah no I'm saying the level of
disloyalty and Ill conduct if it's it
don't say nothing like look it says if
you fear Disobedience if you even think
that she might disobey you so you have
to obey him right you can't resist if
you might rebel against him against his
orders this is what he can do he can
correct you he can send you he cannot
sleep with you or he can beat you or I'm
sorry or and and he can beat you you if
it if it applied to something simple
right like a simple discussion like
almost daily I think husbands and wives
like have simple discussions and like
you're he's going to be like don't
disobey me or whatever but like y'all
laugh it off right like that like that
can happen on a daily yeah so he can
laugh it off by by pimp slapping her huh
no and that I mean laugh it off like as
in you don't like they don't we don't
take it seriously like if my husband
says let's go get pizza and I say no
let's go get like chicken sis like and
you're thinking that's like I'm
disobeying him so no it's not talking
about simple level like that it's
talking about like if you're doing
something like really nasty like you're
on o right it's referring to stuff like
that not simple simple things sister
you're making excuses for something that
is inexcusable and you know it that's
why it's a struggle that's why it's a
struggle look this is what the Bible
says I'm G leave you with this this
Ephesians chapter 5 this is what the
Bible says husbands love your wives even
as Christ also loved the church and gave
himself for it that he might sanctify
and cleanse it with the washing of Water
by the word so you see so look so ought
men to love their wives as their own
bodies he that loveth his wife loves
himself for no man ever yet hated his
own flesh but nourishes and cherishes it
even as the the Lord the church so just
as God loves the church meaning the
Believers the body of Christ the
churches are are people who believe just
as Christ the lord loves the church and
he gave himself for us the Bible says
the hus husbands are to do the same to
their wives that's how we're supposed to
act how God acts towards us not beating
them not striking you even lightly do
you see the difference because
Christianity is just like very like
Supple it's very like oh love love love
love and Islam is very like firm so
you're going to get into real like uh
which one which which one would you say
is better one that says to beat your
wife or one that says to love your wife
which one is better no no no that's not
the way that it's saying it right Islam
is breaking down like everything that
you go through in marriage yours is just
like love your husband love your
wife look at this look at this sister
look men so ought men to love their
wives as their own bodies like duh God
is going to say that duh but you don't
you need something more than that when
you're like freaking married like don't
you need some more like this is no this
is what you need right here to make sure
that you're else what else does like
what what a what a husband would since
you're supposed to love your H your wife
just as you love your own body would a
man beat his own self if he loves
himself would he beat himself first of
all who's beating who no in Islam
there's no beating sister just answer
the question would a man beat himself if
he loves himself don't try to trap me
God logic there's no beating in this L I
like you a lot man you're fun okay well
anyways I'm going to let you go okay all
right bye thank you take care have a
good day